que mueve a la gente
banderas oro ejércitos
no
las historias
nada es más poderoso que una buena
historia
muchos que sois fanáticos del juego de
tronos reconoceréis estas palabras en
boca de tyrion lannister en el último
capítulo
y esa frase encierra una verdad muy
profunda porque es verdad las historias
son poderosas pero porque son poderosas
todos nosotros estamos continuamente
exponiéndonos a historias a través de
series películas libros novelas de
distintos géneros
así que
nos importa saber qué poder tienen las
historias sobre cada uno de nosotros
y os voy a contar una pequeña anécdota
personal acerca de como una historia de
ficción me cambió la vida
yo había terminado el bachillerato y
tenía sólo dos clases claras que quería
estudiar periodismo y que quería hacerlo
en españa'
mi padre no estaba muy de acuerdo porque
el pobre con toda la razón porque había
sido un desastre de estudiante durante
la secundaria vamos que nadie podía
apostar un duro por mí y entonces
pues ante la negativa de mi padre pues
yo bajé los brazos me resigné y dije
bueno pues voy a intentar estudiar una
carrera que sea afín al negocio familiar
que sea útil
y empecé a administración de empresas
con muy poco entusiasmo
cuando cursaba el primer semestre iba a
clase y de repente en una intersección
con el rabillo del ojo alcancé a ver que
venía un coche en contravía a toda
velocidad y se incrustaba contra mi
puerta
perdí la conciencia
lo siguiente que haya recuerdo es estar
sentada en una sala desconocida como una
señora amabilísima que me ofrecía agua y
me preguntaba cómo estaba y entonces yo
obviamente que le iba a decir que me
encontraba fatal me dolía todo vamos por
dolor me dolían hasta las pestañas
y en ese momento
yo no sabía si a lo mejor tenía algún
daño grave una hemorragia interna yo que
sea un poco película era tomic no pero
de verdad me lo planteé
y recordé en ese momento una historia en
concreto una parábola para los socios
cristianos católicos
seguramente suena la parábola de los
talentos para los que no suena pues os
la voy a resumir muy muy brevemente
un señor tenía tres siervos lo llama y
les dice que se va de viaje
a uno le entrega cinco talentos al otro
la entrega a dos talentos y el otro
entrega a uno a cada uno según su
capacidad
y se va
en 4 se va el primero sale a negociar
con sus cinco talentos y gana otro 5 lo
mismo hacer el segundo
negociados ganados
pero el tercero
no se ocurre mejor cosa que el
talento hacer un huequito en la tierra y
enterrarlo
después de mucho tiempo vuelve el señor
y les pide cuentas
entonces el que había
recibido 5 le dice pues mira en
negociados 5 y gana otro 5 a quienes lo
que estudio
el que él recibió 2 lo mismo
y el rato que llega el tercero le dice
o sea que tú eres un señor duro y que
cosechas donde no siembras así que me
dio miedo
y lo que hice fue enterrar el talento en
la tierra así que aquí tienes lo que
estudio
el señor enfadado le dice
eres un siervo malo y perezoso
por lo menos lo que podrías haber hecho
es ir y dejar el talento
a los banqueros para que cuando yo volví
estuviese lo mío más los intereses
con esto no estoy diciendo que tenéis
que salir de aquí corriendo abrir una
cuenta de ahorros en ningún banco
simplemente
lo que yo pensé en ese momento es que me
identificaba mucho con aquel siervo de
un talento me había resignado no había
luchado más por mi sueño
estaba enterrando el talento
y en ese momento hice
una decisión conmigo mismo que si salgo
de ésta si no me muero de algo de aquí
al llegar a la ambulancia
voy a cambiar
voy a ser hasta lo imposible por cumplir
mi meta y efectivamente cuando me
recupere en secreto aplique a una
universidad española me aceptaron y ya
con la carta de admisión pues
y mi familia decidió que lo mejor era
dejarme ir
no solamente estudié periodismo además
puedo estudiar filosofía encontré mi
vocación literaria como poeta esa
parábola me cambió la vida para siempre
normalmente pensamos en las historias
exclusivamente en términos de
entretenimiento
me entretienen más me entretienen menos
me gustan más me gustan menos
sin embargo las ideas tienen el poder de
cambiarnos no solamente de entretenerlos
pueden cambiar modificar nuestra
identidad personal para bien o para mal
las historias de ficción que figuran
nuestra manera de entendernos a nosotros
mismos de entender a los demás y de
entender el mundo que nos rodea
cuando cursaba el doctorado en filosofía
estudia precisamente este tema
un filósofo muy influyente del siglo 20
que se llama paul ricard
y riquer justamente se interesa en el
tema de cómo las historias inciden
y la identidad personal
esa continuidad entre relato y vida
es interesante y tiene muchas
consecuencias
como decir en las historias en primer
lugar nos ayudan a comprender un
concepto tan complejo y tan abstracto
como es el tiempo
san agustín decía en sus confesiones si
me preguntas qué es el tiempo lo sé
pero si lo tengo que explicar no lo sé
las historias nos ayudan a tomar una
serie de acontecimientos sucesivos
inconexos entre sí y darles un sentido
unitario
no en vano muchísimas veces hablamos de
nuestra historia de vida
de la historia de nuestra vida
por otra parte
las historias nos ayudan a comprender
mejor algo que es muy con natural a
nosotros mismos que es las acciones
cuando nos enfrentamos a una buena
historia
vemos cómo se desarrollan en el tiempo
esas acciones y toda su red conceptual
motivos propósitos consecuencias
también conocemos personajes
conocemos su psicología conocemos sus
actitudes cuando hacemos sus reacciones
conocemos sus emociones
conocemos el entorno en el que viven
cómo reaccionan cómo se mueven en ese
entorno social político cultural
por otra parte
hacemos un ejercicio de imaginación
creadora
y eso tiene una doble versión
por una parte está la imaginación
creadora que reconocemos en el autor ese
señor
ha dedicado su tiempo a meter en una
trama una serie de elementos para formar
una historia
pero por otra parte está también nuestra
interpretación de la historia que
también es creativa
cuando especialmente cuando leemos esto
se da menos cuando estamos ante una
pantalla pero especialmente cuando
leemos
nos aburrimos en la obra vivimos dentro
de la obra
nos codeamos con los personajes sufrimos
con sus emociones nos sorprendemos con
las peripecias que pasan
ampliamos nuestra experiencia
y con esa nueva experiencia volvemos al
mundo de la vida
un aprendizaje renovado ampliado a cerca
de la experiencia humana
me diréis qué
todo esto que os he contado es
filosofía en el término tan peyorativo
con que se usa desgraciadamente pero os
cuento que todo esto que os he dicho
perdón
resalta una parte es súper importante
cuando el lector ejerce está imaginación
creativa
y sale al mundo del del lector conecta
el mundo de la obra con el mundo del
lector a esa conexión
ricker lo llama apropiación
por tanto cuando cuanto más y mejores
historias
leemos mejores experiencias
nos apropiamos
tenemos una visión mejorada
intensificada de la vida pasamos de lo
particular limitado de nuestra
experiencia humana a la visión universal
verdadera que nos ofrece las grandes
obras de la literatura
como os decía filosofía bla bla no pues
desde el punto de vista la neurociencia
esto tiene mucho sentido
en 2004 ya como repsol y su equipo de
investigación descubren las llamadas
neuronas espejo
las neuronas de espejos son un grupo de
neuronas muy especiales
tienen varias
actividades simultáneas todas respecto
de las acciones
lo que hacen es interpretar simular
reconocer acciones propias de otros y
también tienen una
e importante labor en la comprensión
lingüística de los verbos de acción no
de cualquier verbo de los verbos de
acción
y cuando hablamos de comprensión
lingüística también hablamos de
narraciones y de historias
qué es lo que ve risoli con su equipo de
investigación pues resulta
que esas neuronas se activan de la misma
manera
cuando yo actuó en primera persona que
cuando observo
actuar a otra persona
la misma acción en primera persona o si
lo observo o si me la cuenta
por otra parte en 2015
el doctor origen son
hizo un experimento muy divertido cogió
a un grupo de sujetos y los puso a ver
una escena de la serie sherlock de la
bbc
y luego ese primer grupo tenía que
contárselo todo eso que ellos habían
visto en primera persona tenían que
contárselo a un segundo grupo que no lo
había visto
una vez que les contaron el segundo
grupo pues hicieron una comparación de
neuroimagen en ambos grupos
y resulta que tanto los primeros como
los segundos sedes iluminaba exactamente
la misma zona cerebral
tanto los que vivieron la experiencia
como a quienes les contaron la
experiencia
esto suena muy cercano
aquello que ya requiere en los años 70
80 llamaba apropiación
el cerebro de ese grupo que vio o que
escuchó el estado era la bbc
tuvo interpretó esa experiencia de la
misma manera en primera persona que si
se lo contara
me diréis
que no a todo el mundo le pasa esto de
una manera así como tan brutal como el
pasó a mí con el accidente
este proceso de apropiación no
necesariamente se da de una manera tan
evidente o tan brusca es un proceso de
sedimentación
es una especie de reserva de
experiencias de paradigmas de acción
que en cualquier momento pueden aflorar
hay un fragmento de un poema del gran
miguel d'ors que dice algo parecido dice
aunque yo nunca he sufrido el complejo
de freud
podemos estar seguros yo desde luego lo
estoy de que en sótanos oscuros de
nuestra vida consciente tenemos parece
broma alojada mucha gente desconocida
que asoma de diferentes maneras cuando
menos te lo esperas
esto es lo que pasa con esa reserva
de experiencia de paradigmas que se va
sedimentando a través de las historias
de ficción de las que nos apropiamos
finalmente
podríamos decir no siempre podemos
elegir nuestras propias experiencias
en cambio si podemos elegir las
experiencias de las que nos apropiamos
entonces yo os voy a hacer una
invitación os voy a poner un reto
tratad de leer las mejores obras de la
literatura universal
a ceros
con lo mejor de la experiencia humana
es que yo no leo bueno en una ley a
nadie o sea sólo para que sepáis en
ecuador tristemente es 1.5 libros per
cápita al año lo que le hemos de decir
con suerte terminamos de leer el
condorito
vale entonces sé que lo que estoy
pidiendo no es fácil
pero os propongo algo 15 minutos diarios
durante dos meses
es decir creado un hábito
santo tomás de aquino decía generar un
hábito no es fácil es arduo ese
esforzado es desagradable
ya con esto os he decepcionado ya del
todo del reto pero pero pero tomás de
aquino nos da una visión muy
esperanzadora junto con aristóteles que
tenía exactamente la misma opinión y que
también la psicología corrobora cuando
repetimos una acción en este caso de
acción de leer
durante un tiempo razonable de manera
sostenida
ese desagrado ese esfuerzo se convierte
en algo estable fácil y placentero
las historias
son como las amistades pueden ser leales
o pueden ser traicioneras
hay un montón de libros un montón de
obras espectaculares esperando entablar
amistad con vosotros
no les dejéis abandonados en la fría
soledad de una estantería
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]